i would like to thank lord dyson and his
team for the report
it is welcome that the bbc accepts lord
dyson's findings in full
which are extremely concerning that bbc
employees
lied and used fake documents to obtain
the interview with my mother
made lurid and false claims about the
royal family which played on her fears
and fueled paranoia
displayed woeful incompetence when
investigating complaints
and concerns about the programme and
were evasive in their reporting to the
media
and covered up what they knew from their
internal investigation
it is my view that the deceitful way the
interview was obtained
substantially influenced what my mother
said
the interview was a major contribution
to making my parents relationship worse
and has since hurt countless others
it brings indescribable sadness to know
that the bbc's failures contributed
significantly
to her fear paranoia and isolation
that i remember from those final years
with her
but what saddens me most is that if the
bbc had properly investigated the
complaints and concerns
first raised in 1995 my mother would
have known
that she had been deceived she was
failed not just by a rogue reporter
but by leaders at the bbc who looked the
other way
rather than asking the tough questions
is my firm view that this panorama
program holds no legitimacy
and should never be aired again it
effectively established a false
narrative
which for over a quarter of a century
has been commercialized by the bbc and
others
this settled narrative now needs to be
addressed by the bbc
and anyone else who has written or
intends to write about these events
in an era of fake news public service
broadcasting
and a free press have never been more
important
these failings identified by
investigative journalists
not only let my mother down and my
family down
they let the public down too